una persona che mi ha scritto perché una
primocanale stavo pensando di portare
dico tutti su un altro canale la che io
apre un nuovo canale in questo preciso
momento
raga non so come chiamarlo raga
gb
raga iscrivetevi ma ndo sta salendo 4
ragazzi
ma tu lago ma che stai a dio che figo
iscrivetevi li mortacci ma promette
civile iscritti aperto da un secondo
intimi descritti 99 si scotta viva
all'esca giocatori iscritti
se arriviamo a cento il record italiano
proprio lui 75 mila iscritti in 3 ore
ragazzi manca solo il record ma ricca
solo il record e 90 mila iscritti in tre
ore e mezza quasi 4 92 attenzione 93
perfetto 7.000 iscritti all'arrivo ecco
noi ci sono persone no si è pagato il
counter devo aggiornare la pagina porca
vacca modà gioco
[Musica]
no no non hanno bannato porca vacca
perché questa cosa questa carta è stato
padano pensavano fossero iscritti falsi
capito che qui ma hanno bannato al 93
è sbandato si è sbandato lazio che
contro mi fa ridere perché non ha senso
cioè noi bannato il canale perché faceva
troppi schizzi ma sono io da avete
interrotto un momento di lei ma poi
potevate bannarmi dopo e dai eccola
basta dire che me li compro basta pure
youtube adesso basta sono veri sono i
miei scritti questi non avete cup così
porca vacca riprendiamo adorava rimasti
male hanno sbagliato ragazzi siamo
ritornati mother padre
mangiare
proprio lui mammamia 100k o buongiorno a
tutti buongiorno a tutti quanti ragazzi
come state passata non è in realtà la
tazza e vuota e festo lo per fare scena
e non è neanche mattina sono quasi le
quattro di pomeriggio siamo in dirittura
d'arrivo per il record italiano in
questo preciso momento siamo a 183 mila
400 19 18 e di ciò 17 in un giorno in un
giorno
ass non lo so grazie di cuore rare
grazie ma giuro non pensavo mai una cosa
definirono tra l'altro delle occhiaia
assurde perché stanotte non ho dormito
niente per l'emozione sembra che sono in
after la cosa più assurda e chiarato
tutto a caso hack completamente a caso
quando ho fatto la live non pensavo mai
di aprire il canale mi è venuto così ho
detto a primo suo canale grazie di
credere in me da sei anni a questa parte
sono veramente con euforico è contento
di aver fatto questo percorso insieme a
voi adesso vi spiego i due premi per
questo traguardo che è arrivato allora
il primo è che questo sabato uscirà una
parodia nuova
la seconda cosa e credo che qua siate
veramente ancora più contenti perché sto
per dare l'annuncio incredibile questo
secondo canale serve per dividere i
contenuti nuovi di fa vj da quelli
vecchi che cosa significa oggi vanno di
moda tante altre cose tipo gli eserciti
di minecraft ma di moda rob l'oxford
neanche io sto portando ogni tanto su
questo canale perché giocati in una
certa maniera mi divertono però alcuni
nostalgici di fa vj non li seguono
seguono soltanto gli horror e queste
cose qua quindi questo canale che voi
state vedendo quindi il mio principale
fa vj tornerà ad essere quello originale
quindi horror quindi ogni tanto li
porterò anche perché l'altro giorno l'ho
giocato in live appunto mi sono
divertito un sacco quindi secondo me può
anche ritornare è più visti giocherò a
super meat boy che ad esso e shell 2
tornerà ad essere fa vj come sempre
stato tutti i contenuti nuovi quindi
quelli che vi ho elencato prima andranno
sul secondo canale vivido queste due
cose in modo tale che chi vuole seguire
1 segue 1 chi vuole seguire l'altro
segue l'altro chi vuole seguirli tutti e
due ville i mono tantissimo
in questo modo finalmente accontentiamo
sia la nuova utenza che quella vecchia
tutti quanti sono contenti e viva la
vita non farò subito un video al giorno
inizierò a capire come funziona a
cercare di capire un po di cose e poi
pian piano mi stabilito quindi un po un
esperimento ai ragazzi attivate anche la
campanella se siete iscritti ai canali
perché gli arrivano le notifiche di
quando carica un video alle 16 precise
che stanno per scoccare ci fermiamo il
counter vediamo quanto abbiamo fatto
attenzione arriva lo sento lo sentivo
ore caiolo sento
eccolo 180 3.686 180 3.686 iscritti in
24 ore
non so cosa dire manco per google a
genchi da ma hanno alzato le mani in
così tante persone grazie
iscrivetevi al secondo canale ragazzi
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
iscrivere i due canali e noi come sempre
ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
belle ragazze